y
[Música]
el presidente de donald trump dejó
entrever en su primer discurso desde su
derrota que podría haber otra
administración en la casa blanca esto lo
hice nuevo cuando se refería a su país
no tendrá un confinamiento nacional pese
a que los casos de covite siguen
marcando récords se centró además en los
avances de la vacuna
honduras nicaragua y guatemala pidieron
fondos para enfrentar la destrucción que
la tormenta de está dejó en la región
donde al menos 150 personas perdieron la
vida la búsqueda de más de un centenar
de desaparecidos sigue y ahora se espera
la llegada de la tormenta y ota que
podría convertirse en un huracán mayor
desde este domingo tenemos reportes
desde nicaragua
por quinto día consecutivo miles de
peruanos protestaron contra el gobierno
transitorio de manuel merino al que
tildan de ilegítimo parte del congreso
también mostró su rechazo al ejecutivo
al tiempo que continúan las críticas de
organizaciones internacionales por la
violenta represión en las
manifestaciones
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france24 soy valentina torre sánchez
vamos a iniciar en eeuu porque tras ocho
días sin pronunciarse el presidente de
donald trump ofreció sus primeras
declaraciones públicas sin hacer ninguna
mención a los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales incluso aunque
minutos antes de su intervención se
anunció que job aiden ganó en el estado
de georgia lo que lo lleva a acumular
306 votos electorales de los 538 en su
discurso trump insinuó la posibilidad de
que haya un nuevo gobierno en la casa
blanca al tiempo que se negó a tener
otro confinamiento pese a los récords
diarios de casos de kobe 19 may day
lewis idealmente no entraremos en un
confinamiento yo no lo haré esta
administración no irá a un confinamiento
pase lo que pase en el futuro quién sabe
qué administración será supongo que el
tiempo lo dirá pero puedo decirles que
esta administración no ir al
confinamiento
en centroamérica los presidentes de
honduras nicaragua y guatemala pidieron
apoyo monetario al banco centroamericano
de integración económica para enfrentar
la destrucción que la tormenta de eta de
jóvenes
países y alertaron que la región puede
verse aún más golpeada con la llegada de
la tormenta y otra que se prevé para
este domingo los mandatarios hicieron un
llamado al fondo verde del clima de la
onu mecanismo que ayuda a países en
desarrollo a mitigar los efectos del
cambio climático eta dejó más de 150
muertos y al menos un centenar de
desaparecidos en la zona
vamos a ir juntos a perseguir los fondos
verdes para que estos nos sirvan como
garantías en la constitución de los
créditos de seguro agrícola y los
seguros de la infraestructura
estratégica de nuestros países de manera
que cada una de estas de estos desastres
que son consecuencias de los cambios
climáticos no lo tengamos que estar
afrontando los países con más deuda y
más endeudamiento porque va a llegar un
momento en que no lo vamos a poder
soportar vamos hasta nicaragua donde se
encuentra nuestro corresponsal jorge
hurtado jorge buenos días las
autoridades ya han cuantificado los
daños que dejó eta en la zona
así es el caribe del país en -20
comunidades indígenas aún no se
recuperan de los daños causados por
encaje impacto nicaragua en categoría 4
según reporte oficial las pérdidas
calculan en 172 millones de dólares un
total de 1.890 casas resultaron
totalmente destruidas y otras 8 mil 30
con daños parciales un total de 47 mil
personas tuvieron que refugiarse en más
de 300 albergues durante el martes el
jueves de la semana pasada cuando el
trato con nicaragua el total de
habitantes impuestos por más de dos
millones de personas acá en caguas con
un reporte oficial y aunque el gobierno
no reconoce pérdidas humanas se sabe que
al menos dos mineros artesanales
fallecieron tras el paso del huracán en
este país jorge y sólo han pasado unos
días pero ya se espera la llegada de
yota como posible huracán se prevé que
impacte la misma zona de eta'
así que se espera que yo trato que hay
tierra en nicaragua convertido de un
huracán de categoría 3 a más y su ruta
es bastante similar a la técnica de
seguir comenzaron nuevas agrupaciones en
este nivel del país por esta nueva
tormenta y hay albergues que aún están
repletos de personas que permanecen ahí
desde la semana pasada por la crecida de
ríos la obstrucción infraestructura bien
y también la destrucción de sus
viviendas son expertos locales
este nuevo huracán tendrá un impacto
mayor al geta y preocupa a varias
organizaciones de sociedad civil que han
denunciado la politización de la
emergencia y alertan que el gobierno
accede y persigue a quienes recaudan
ayuda humanitaria para los damnificados
porque muchas gracias por esta
información continuaremos muy pendientes
del desarrollo de esta tormenta en la
zona
vamos a suramérica porque miles de
peruanos volvieron a las calles para
continuar protestando contra el gobierno
transitorio del presidente manuel merino
al que consideran ilegítimo la
movilización del viernes se desarrolló
de forma pacífica luego de que las
autoridades reprimieron la jornada del
jueves varios legisladores se unieron al
rechazo ciudadano
porque organizaciones internacionales
continuaron criticando al gobierno de
transición naciones unidas- manifestó su
profunda preocupación por la actuación
de la policía
más temprano conversamos con nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
quien nos contó sobre la nueva marcha
nacional que está convocada para esta
tarde
los peruanos saldrán nuevamente a las
calles para repudiar al parlamento por
destituir al presidente al presidente de
martín vizcarra y poner en su lugar a
manuel merino para lo que es este la
capital en lima se ha citado una gran
movilización a la plaza san martín esto
ha sido a través de las redes sociales
se iniciará la marcha a partir de la 2
de la tarde en cambio en otros sectores
de la capital se realizarán
movilizaciones a partir de las 4 la idea
es una nueva estrategia que han tomado
los manifestantes realizar
movilizaciones descentralizadas que les
permitan llevar mayor personas a las
protestas los que participan los
organizadores han señalado que ellos no
van a dar tregua en las calles con las
protestas hasta forzar la renuncia de
manuel merino vamos ahora hasta mexico
porque el capitán jose martínez crespo
se entregó a la justicia luego de que se
emitiera una orden de captura por su
presunta implicación en el caso de la
desaparición de los 43 normalistas de
ayotzinapa en 2014
martínez crespo es el primer integrante
del ejército detenido en el caso y está
acusado de delincuencia organizada en la
modalidad de narcotráfico el militar era
parte del 27º batallón de infantería en
iguala en el estado de guerrero donde
ocurrió la desaparición de los
estudiantes
vamos ahora hasta beirut porque el
gobierno del líbano decretó dos semanas
de confinamiento ante el aumento elevado
de casos de coronavirus el país se
encuentra sumido en la crisis económica
ahondada por la pandemia que mantiene en
alerta a las autoridades sanitarias y
que han recordado el déficit de unidades
hospitalarias en el país desde beirut
nuestra corresponsable tel bonet nos da
más detalles de esta crítica situación
el líbano ha superado ya los 2.000 casos
de contagios diarios de coronavirus y
las muertes ascienden a unas 800 por la
pandemia por lo general el líbano tiene
deficiencia de camas hospitalarias y
ahora además se suma que los cuatro
principales hospitales de beirut
resultaron seriamente dañados por la
explosión del puerto el 4 de agosto y
todavía no están a pleno rendimiento
para que la cosa no se vaya de las manos
las autoridades libanesas han decretado
dos semanas de confinamiento que
comienza hoy y un toque de queda desde
las 5 de la tarde hasta las 5 de la
mañana todos los comercios no esenciales
están cerrados es decir desde bares
restaurantes centros comerciales hasta
instituciones públicas y centros
educativos desde las guarderías hasta
las universidades la medida también
afecta a la movilidad y únicamente
podrán circular vehículos con matrícula
para un día y al día siguiente vehículos
con matrícula impar muchos comerciantes
temen que el confinamiento se pueda
alargar un tiempo y esto será un duro
a la economía local que ya está
sufriendo seriamente por la crisis
finalizamos esta misión muchas gracias
por su sintonía y continúen con nosotros
en france24 punto com
[Música]